10) The Chinese wall is the only man-made object visible from space.
To be able to see something on Earth from space, it must be quite big, the 8047 km long
Chinese wall is certain. But it is only 9 meters at its widest.
Here is a photo taken from the International Space station, 321 km above the earth.
Can you see the Chinese wall between the mountain tops?
Here, right? No, that is a river, the wall is actually here. Even if you would guess the place
by pure happiness, this photo was taken with a telephoto lens, so out of the window
from the space station it looks more like this - which is pretty clear the Chinese wall
let count as "not visible." With regard to the man-made part of this myth
our glorious man-made cities that pour light into space are certainly visible.
9) Cracking your knuckles causes rheumatism. Socially repulsive? Yes. Causes rheumatism
later in your life as a punishment of karma? No. 8) People only use 10% of their brains.
If you have never seen medical drama in the last 30 years, you would have seen it
that doctors now have machines that can look into people in brains and, unlike
what many people think, 90% of neurons don't sit idle all day.
Although scientists do not yet know exactly what each part is doing, they do know that all
small parts are important. So if you think you have 90% of your brain
can spoon out and would still be fine, then you might only use 10% of it.
7) Eskimos have hundreds of words for snow.
This is technically correct, but misleading. Some languages, such as German, like it
words put together by stringing several smaller words together, making German words
sometimes absurdly long. The languages ​​of the Inuit also use compound words
so instead of saying 'yellow snow' as you say in English, if Inuit speaker combined
the two become in one, but it's not really a new word, but rather a stroke of grammar.
So technically, Eskimos have 100 ways to describe snow ... but then every one has
andre language that too. 6) You need 8 glasses of water every day.
Although some people would undoubtedly benefit from drinking more water and less
junk, there is no scientific evidence that 8 glasses of water per day is the recommended amount
and sometimes it seems that it might be too much. And now that we are talking about water ...
5) Water from the tap is bad but spring water is good. If you live in a paradise, free of regulations
from the government such as, say, Somalia, then you may have good reasons to prefer spring water than
drinking tap water. But modern, functioning countries have health regulations
with regard to both types of water. In addition, water is extremely tight as far as transportation
from those pristine mountain peaks and glaciers enormously expensive making spring water
companies don't bother. 'Source' water is often just local tap water
with a chic label and a huge increase in price. 4) Chewing gum takes seven years to get through
digestion system. This is quite easy to refute yourself, but
it's easy to see why most people don't try this experiment themselves.
3) Blood in your veins is blue. The idea here is that the blood in veins is blue
and does not turn red until it is exposed to the oxygen in the air.
This thought is not unreasonable. After all, veins already appear blue and medical diagrams
show arteries as red and veins as blue, but that's the same mistake as' Mountain
Dew 'is green because it is in a green bottle. Pour it out and discover that Mountain Dew actually
piss yellow, which is probably the reason why she is storing it in a green bottle
sit. The next time you have blood taken from a vein,
take a look. What color is it? Red. How much oxygen is there in a good syringe?
No. Unless you are a horseshoe crab or Plavalaguna,
your blood is not blue. 2) Fan death
This myth is South Korea's specialty. Here it is believed that if you spend too much time with
an electric fan spends in an enclosed space, it will use up all your oxygen and
you will choke. How exactly a fan made of lifeless, anaerobic
plastic, competes for your oxygen is unclear, but hilariously have South Korean
fan producers - who should know better - added timers to fans to counteract
that they would stay on too long. 1) People swallow 8 spiders annually while they sleep.
Probably while you are in bed, helpless, unconscious with your face wide open, everyone
eight spiders find their way into your mouth and you swallow them reflexively.
This is of course ridiculous: spiders love hot, humid places so eight is probably a much lower bet.